hey guys Justin hey Walt here with an
unboxing but also a little bit of a PSA
Grand Theft Auto 5 is out today was out
yesterday I mean if you digitally
downloaded it but maybe you are walking
by your local gaming establishment and
you saw GTA 5 in its box and thought oh
there's a special edition GTA that I
didn't know about no there's there's
actually nothing special about the
retail edition of GTA 5 on PC it's just
in a really really big box you might
recall that the game takes a lot of
gigabytes to to install on your computer
whether you're downloading it or not and
on disc it's still gonna take up 65
gigabytes so let's open this up and see
exactly what we get is there a special
edition handgun in there it's our
soundtrack it's a very nice looking box
but ultimately it is seven discs very
nice looking discs but there's not much
else to them so why does it come on so
many discs when can you save so much
space if you just put it on a USB or a
blu-ray disc well not everyone has those
things and honestly these things are so
much cheaper to make just think about
the time what 10 15 years ago when AOL
was sending discs in the mail constantly
and you were just using them as frisbees
that's where DVDs have gotten now it's a
lot cheaper to produce these and so
that's why you're going to get this
really big set rather than just a single
blu-ray or a really handy USB stick but
that's not all that you get in the box
it does look like there is also a
million dollars in in-game cash please
don't steal this code a really chintzy
looking instruction manual that is all
of four pages it probably tells you how
dangerous the game is and it might kill
you and of course the GTA lo santos map
which also comes in the xbox one ps4 ps3
xbox 360 version of the game other
so that's the GTA 5 PC retail edition
nothing terribly special but that's why
it's so big